[Music]
all right so what is french for oops i
did it again emmanuel macron inviting
the rage of uh many of the unvaccinated
in france by saying he wants to piss
them all and make life very difficult
for them if they don't get vaccinated
including not welcoming in bars and
restaurants and public venues
protests are being planned right now and
even many of the
vaccinated are saying he went too far
his goal of course is to see as many
french citizens or vaccinated as
possible
to deal with the omicron variant right
now that is all the world's rage even
though the cases are not as serious
there are certainly more of them to dr
bob lajita the saint joseph's director
for autoimmune and rheumatic diseases
doctor good to see you i'll spare you my
emmanuel macron impression and french
impression of that but i did want to get
your reaction to how he has vilified the
unvaccinated and plans to make life
difficult for them what do you think of
that
yes neil well this is three months
before his election this is a gutsy move
by monsieur macron the president and he
really is
he's reflecting the anger of the french
public against those who are not
vaccinated and actually there's a lot of
vaccination in france somewhat near 70
to 80 percent of the population he is
doing what monsieur de blasio the former
mayor of new york city did and
essentially prohibits people from
squeezing them out of public events and
i don't think this is going to fly in
the united states if president biden has
any idea that this may be the way he
should go
you know um the supreme court is taking
up this issue of vaccine mandates i
don't want to go back and forth on that
but it might already be too late right i
mean we're at the point now where 200
million americans have at least gotten
one shot i think um 60 some odd percent
two or three percent uh
are in that position so i'm i'm
wondering uh if all of that might be a
moot point what do you think yeah i
think that a mandate a national mandate
would be a big mistake america is based
on freedom of what you want to do with
your own body
i told you many times before as well as
others that i think that certain
professions should be mandated to be
vaccinated such as doctors nurses police
fire ems and maybe
school teachers for sure but that's
about where the mandates should stop if
you start doing that to the general
public as i see with my patients they
get extremely angry and very very
agitated when you tell them that they
must get the booster they must get
vaccinated and so on although it is a
good public health measure
you know
already we've had four million cases
largely omicron in the past week doctor
versus four million cases in the first
six months of the pandemic
what do you mean
we're going to have overwhelming
infection it's not a question of whether
but a question of when i suspect
everyone in the country will eventually
be infected the good news is neil that
this may provide us with the immunity
the hurt immunity that we've been
waiting for simply because you either
get infected or you get vaccinated if
your immune system then responds to this
coronavirus the only thing that would
knock us out of the box would be a new
variant and as you know the new variants
occur in those who are unvaccinated and
and so that's troublesome and it's
around the world not just here in the
united states
what do you make of this other verdi ihu
i i hope i'm referring to it correctly
doctor uh yes it's been raising some
concerns should we worry about it
well until the data come in we shouldn't
worry about it that is a
that's been described by a french
genomics institute which the ihu is uh
all about and it's from a guy that came
in from cameroon and as you know in
various parts of africa the rate of uh
vaccination is exceedingly low sometimes
less than 10 percent of the population
so that's where these variants are
popping up and they're popping up
because some of these people who are
immuno suppressed hang on to the virus
for months and that's when variation and
mutation can occur so i wouldn't lose
sleep over the ihu i've been talking
about the lambda the mu and the omicron
for many many months and only the
omicron has spread like wildfire through
the world and will provide us with
significant immunity and not bad
clinical symptoms
you know when we were last chatting
doctor you were talking about this virus
being with us forever the president says
he doesn't think covet is here
to stay
are you right is he right
i think he's wrong i think covet is here
to stay just like influenza is here to
stay and i predict that when the
pandemic goes away we're going to have
an endemic virus and perhaps people will
be creative and create a vaccine that
will include both the flu and the
coronavirus every year or maybe every
other year depending on how the
scientists really feel about its endemic
nature and how bad it proceeds
probably like the flu every season
dr bob lajita you've been such a
constant and reassuring source on this
through all the craziness i know i speak
for everybody certainly here we
appreciate that so continue
keeping us calm doctor thank you thanks
neil